- Welcome to StarTalk, I'm
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson,
your personal astrophysicist.
And I'm also the director
of New York City's Hayden Planetarium
at the American Museum of Natural History.
And I got with me my co-host, Chuck Nice.
- That's right.
- Chuck Nice comic tweeting?
- Thank you sir, yes
that is indeed correct.
- There you go.
- @ChuckNiceComic.
Was there a Chuck Nice already taken?
Is that what happened?
- Yes, it was me.
- (laughing) What did you...
- I actually didn't like
myself enough to cancel that,
and so I just started a whole new one.
I'm starting all over
again, @ChuckNiceComic.
- In case you didn't laugh at my tweet,
just remember that it's @ChuckNiceComic,
that's how that works.
- Exactly.
You're also a host of
a spin-off of StarTalk
that we're all quite proud
of, Playing With Science.
'Cause what happened was
we had of our guests,
the portfolio of our guests,
the ones that were professional athletes
developed their own following basically.
We figured let's spawn
that into its own show.
- I have spawned with
professional athletes.
(Neil laughs)
Never thought I'd be able
to say those words, yes.
- And your co-host on that is?
- Gary O'Reilly who's a performer,
a former professional footballer.
- Football area for the UK.
- Crystal Palace and--
- Very cool.
And today we're talking
about the evolution
of personal technology.
- [Chuck] Wow.
- Indeed.
- That's a very rapid evolution.
- Yes, it is, and I feature my interview
with YouTube vlogger
and all-around sensation
in this niche, we have Marques Brownlee,
featuring in my interview.
- The kid?
Yes.
- That kid?
- Yes.
- Who does all the unboxing and stuff?
- I love that kid.
And he's also known online as what?
- MKBHD.
- There you go.
- I love that kid.
There you go.
Featuring my interview with him.
- Cool.
- That was fun, just,
'cause I feel like you okay,
go to bed now, it's past,
I felt like being his father.
But no, he's got his own world,
like create his own world.
- He's big stuff.
- Now since I only have
marginal expertise on this,
generally we go out and
find the real expertise
as we did today, in studio we
have science and tech writer
for The New York Times and other outlets
including Wired, Clive Thompson, Clive.
- Good to be here, my friend.
- [Neil] Welcome.
- It's great to be here.
- Dude, dude, so you,
you have a book from a few years ago.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Smarter Than You Think"?
- Yep.
- "How Technology Is Changing
Our Minds For The Better.
- Yes sir.
- Wow, that is so counterintuitive.
- You are the only one in the house.
- I'm the only one holding
down that argument.
- Everybody else thinks
it's making us dumber.
- If you need that book,
I have one for you.
- All right, all right, none of us agree
with whatever you could
have possibly put in there.
So in my interview with Marques Brownlee,
he runs a YouTube channel, MKBHD,
it's a YouTube channel.
Five million subscribers,
700 million video views
and he reviews new tech and gadgets
that you might think of buying
or that you already bought
and then you learned you
shouldn't have. (laughs)
So any idea what makes it so popular?
'Cause I'm not a first adopter,
so I don't have to chase
the latest unwrapping.
- But see that's why it's so popular.
- Why?
- Is what you just said,
"I'm not a first adopter."
He is the first adopter in your stead.
- Somebody has to be--
- Somebody's gotta be the first.
- The first adopter.
- And that's what this kid does.
- And also frankly I mean--
- I gotta stop calling him a kid.
He's a grown man, I'm just old.
Okay, go ahead, sorry.
- I think he's sort of an
exemplar of what's happening
at this new generation
of sort of broadcasters
are growing up not on TV but online.
And they're really, I mean
he's really good at it.
You look at it, it's
just beautifully shot,
he's just oozing charisma.
- So in modern times one
perhaps shouldn't even make
the distinction between
being on TV or being online.
- Yeah, in a weird way, I mean YouTube
is such a funny old phrase, right?
Because tube, I mean who actually
watching YouTube remembers--
(Neil and Chuck talk over each other)
- [Neil] None of them.
- None of them, I barely do.
I've got a couple of
young kids in grade school
and middle school and for them,
what they watch, where they
learn things from is YouTube.
Once we got a TV box hooked up to YouTube,
it's just YouTube on TV.
There's no actual TV being watched.
- Or they don't make the distinction.
- That's right, absolutely true.
- So that's an emergent fact.
- I think it's beyond just
not making the distinction
'cause I have also an 11-year-old.
He is resistant to television.
The fact that he has
to do it on their time
and their schedule actually--
- And sit down in front of a
thing attached to the wall.
- It upsets him, it's like how dare you?
- And there's also sort of I mean,
I think there's kind of
an authenticity that comes
or apparent authenticity,
hard to say how authentic it really is.
But from seeing someone
who looks maybe more
like someone you might
actually know doing this.
Like my kids watch all
these Minecraft videos
and it's just someone doing Minecraft.
Then a little box up in
the corner showing them
in their crappy little room--
- That's what my son does.
- There you go.
It's how to play that game better.
- That's right, yeah.
- Right, right.
So the YouTube feels
more authentic and more,
like there's a real person there
than a very glossy TV show.
- And they get like 12
million views. (laughs)
- On how to execute some
maneuver and that situation.
So I sat down with Marques.
So he's well known on the web of course
and I just asked him how
he got started on YouTube.
So let's check it out.
Apparently you've been doing this
since you were three years
old or something, is that--
- For a while, a number of years.
More than a majority of my life.
- Most of your life, so
more than half your life.
And how old are you now?
- So I'm 22.
- You getting old, yeah.
I'll tell you how it happens later on.
It's just downhill from 22.
- Yeah.
So you're into gadgets.
- Yeah, into all kinds of tech.
I got into cameras and I got
into all the tech around me,
and then this sort of
emerged into making videos
about the tech.
- On a YouTube channel
that's a hugely popular place
for people to go.
- Right, and it didn't start that way.
It started as just me making
videos for like myself
just to have that exist somewhere,
and then slowly people
started to discover it
and then it sort of grew from that.
- So doesn't it cost money?
To review a gadget you
gotta own the gadget
or somehow obtain it.
So what did you do?
- I was in school, so I was
using a laptop for school,
so I reviewed the laptop.
And I reviewed a bunch of
free software on the laptop.
And then I started viewing
paid things that I bought,
maybe the cooler for the laptop.
That's the kind of stuff
that got you off the ground
and then you sort of proceed
to check out more elaborate
or extravagant things.
- And then people come to depend on you.
- A little bit, a little bit, yeah.
- "I'm not buying it unless Marques--"
- When it's something you use as daily
as like a smartphone for example,
that's the kind of thing you do actually
put a lot of research into and watch
a whole bunch of videos on
before you actually buy it.
- So when did you realize you
started having a following?
- I think one of the turning
points is a video I did
about a web browser, when
Safari by Apple came to Windows.
I made a video about that,
woke up the next morning
and I had a couple of
thousand views from people
who weren't subscribed.
And that was kind of a light bulb moment
like oh, people actually kind of care
about this timely information.
- And by then you had just
turned five years old. (laughs)
- I think I was probably about
15 so I'll give myself that.
- Same difference. (laughs)
I just wondered, did your
parents worry about you?
If you're just playing
with gadgets, it's like,
"He'll never amount to anything.
"He's just playing with these toys."
- I gotta guess yes.
(Neil laughs)
I don't actually know the
answer but I would guess yeah.
- It's one of those I'm betting,
it's one of those things.
He'll never amount,
they're shaking their head
as you're just playing
with your electronic toys.
- Just editing a video, doing nothing.
- He's just doing nothing. (laughs)
Such is the, always the case
when the next generation
defines what the future will be.
So Clive, how would you distinguish
your childhood from his?
'Cause you started writing and you cared
about the same gadgets
and software that he did,
but not in that era.
- That's right, yeah, I mean this is like,
I grew up in the 80s, and
then when I got out of college
in the 90s there's no smartphones yet,
there's barely an internet, right?
There was like a lot of these text BBSs--
- Al Gore had to invent it first, yeah.
- Absolutely, message boards!
- Message board, yeah, that's what it was.
- Yeah, so I kind of had them and like,
so I could see the future
coming with message boards.
I could sort of figure out
what was happening, right?
But yeah, my youth is very
very different and I think--
- You would have come of age during
the earliest cellphones then, correct?
Mid 90s, was it?
- No, no, I was well into my 20s
when the mobile phones came out basically.
- Did you get the shoulder mounted one?
- Exactly, ones you can
use to deflect bullets.
Yeah, I know.
- Also calling Mars.
- Exactly.
(Neil laughs)
I mean I think it was very
different and I think,
I think they're some of the things
I would have liked about it.
I mean I look at the online world now
and I think I wish I
had some of this stuff.
I was in a band in high school, right?
So we make a couple of,
a small EP of music.
Who heard that?
No one, absolutely nobody.
- So you wish you were
born 15 years later?
Really what you're saying.
- In some respect--
- His band would have put
the thing out on YouTube
and ended up on Ellen, right?
- Ellen would have found it.
- And before you know
it, it's just like whoa.
- Okay, so I try to take a
cosmic view on these matters
and I just try to imagine in 20 years,
Marques Brownlee saying,
"Gee, I wish I was born 15 years later."
'Cause there's something else
that would have made some next
generation even more potent.
- YouTube of the mind.
- Of the mind, yeah.
We got a USB into the--
- You just jack in and
you close your eyes.
You don't even have to close your eyes.
- And just sends it to
wherever it's, right, right.
Implants in people, and we're
looking back in these days
as how archaic they were.
So I'm just curious, in
terms of YouTube as a site,
are there other sites
now, as I understand it,
Facebook is now a huge
access point for videos.
- I would say also Snapchat actually,
or Snap as they now call it.
It's a really big deal.
They started this channel,
it's kind of like,
where people do like
semi-professional videos
but there's people who have
just kind of blown up on Snap,
I have trouble calling
it Snap, on Snapchat.
That's a very very big video
area for young people now too.
YouTube is still the gorilla in the room
but there are others.
- So Snapchat.
The thing about--
- Snap.
Snap, right, crackle, pop,
that's what I know when I say Snap.
But Snap, the thing is that it seems
like all of their technology,
they're quite innovative
but it seems like all their technology
just gets stolen by these other sites.
- That's right, yeah.
- How are they going to stay in business?
- I don't know, 'cause Facebook basically,
Instagram essentially
copied everything they did
and now it turns out that
Instagram's blowing up
'cause people are doing that
kind of quick viral video thing
on Instagram, that's a good question.
I don't know.
- Okay, okay, if you don't know who,
give me the guy who does know.
- Wheel him in.
- So with phones coming out,
the next generation of
phones look pretty expensive,
the next iPhone is gonna be up there.
How influential do you
think those reviews are
in people's buying decisions?
- Well, I think they're awfully big.
I mean when I talk to people and ask them
how they learn about things.
I'll ask them and they're
like yeah, it's all YouTube,
all YouTube, they immediately go there
to try and figure out
what something looks like,
what it feels like, what it works like
and whether or not they
should spend money on it.
So YouTube has become
the conduit for learning
about something before you buy it.
- [Chuck] Absolutely.
- So I asked Marques
to just sort of reflect
on how technology has evolved
over his short number
of years reviewing it,
so let's check it out.
So you're 22 now.
So in your long career as reviewer,
what would you say changed most
since you were 15 let's say?
Or that has impressed you
most for what has changed.
- I'll give two things.
One I talk about a lot
of handheld electronics
like smartphones,
tablets, laptops, displays
have impressed me a lot and--
- The quality and resolution, crispiness.
- Detail, the crispiness,
all that stuff a lot
in the last couple of years
and also more recently cameras.
Cameras in smartphones,
cameras in laptops, the
front-facing cameras
but especially in smartphones
have gotten a lot better.
But the number one thing
I'd say is the displays.
- The quality of displays
has enabled a whole industry
to land in that medium,
isn't that correct?
- Yeah.
- It's not just making what
you saw previously better,
it is opening up entire new industries,
is that a fair statement?
- Virtual reality is an example,
where you wouldn't have a
super high-resolution display
right up against your face
with a lens to focus on it
to put you in another world.
That would not be
possible with the displays
four or five years ago.
- Because that close to your face,
the lower resolution would
be unsellable to you.
Is that a fair...
- [Marques] Yeah.
- Okay, so we've crossed
certain thresholds
of device innovation.
- Yeah, Apple might use
the term retina display
to describe a display where
the pixel density is so great
that your eye cannot
discern individual pixels.
Pretty much every phone has a
retina display at this point
where five years ago
that was not the case.
And even the photos you
take with the cameras
getting so detailed and
such high resolution,
that again the type of images
you can take out of a camera
on your smartphone are
often better than something
you get from a dedicated camera
like seven, eight years ago.
- Yeah, so Clive, can you
explain why this is happening?
- Yeah, it's just demand
and supply, right?
- No, I didn't know the demand
of stuff that I'm buying now.
It's like oh my gosh, I
guess it's kind of cool.
- Once people start,
once the iPhone came out
and people realized that they
want, 10 years ago, right.
iPhone comes out and they don't want
a little flip phone anymore,
they want something that
has a screen on it, right?
So that produces an enormous
demand for those screens.
And over in Asia, the factories
start working and working
and working and working and
the price drops dramatically.
And so the high end is always
chasing more and more pixels
and more and more resolution
and greater brightness.
But even that has dropped and dropped
and dropped and dropped
to the point where like,
it's an expensive part of the phone
but it's amazing how cheap you
can get really nice screens
now over in Asia.
- So all right, now I have a
nice screen but like I said,
I never would have imagined
using my cell phone saying yeah,
I want to take a picture
with my cellphone,
this was not an urge.
I don't think anybody had that urge.
- I think what might have driven that--
- I thought they were
forcing it on me initially.
- Yeah, they did, they
were if you remember.
And I think what did it was
believe it or not, apps.
The advent of apps and these photo apps
that allowed you to do your
own little like photoshopping
and to manipulate images
and then post them.
- Yeah, I mean I think in many ways
a tipping point was
probably Instagram, right?
So that was the first thing
where you could take a picture
and you could put a filter on
it to make it look prettier
than what you did, right?
And this was an intentional
thing that Kevin Systrom,
the guy that invented it was talking about
with his girlfriend
when he was designing it
about sharing photos.
And she said to him, they
were talking about it
and she was like,
"The problem is I don't
want to share my photos
"if they don't look as good as yours."
He's a big analog camera guy and he said,
"Well, that's because
I'm using all these films
"that produce these
lovely filtering effect."
She said, "Well, you
need to put some filters
"in that thing."
Lo and behold, that's exactly what worked.
Because you could take
pictures, make them look pretty,
instantly share them, that took off.
- Are we gonna go up against,
is there some Moore's law
of personal technology?
- [Clive] Yeah, there is.
- And is that gonna end?
- Well, first of all guys, let me just say
that there are some people
who may not be familiar
with what Moore's Law is.
I mean I know what it is--
- Other people might not know.
- Other people guess they many
not, but what is Moore's law?
- In brief Moore's Law is the observation
several decades ago that computer chips
were getting basically twice
as fast every 18 months, right?
And that's because they could make
the components smaller
and smaller and smaller.
They are now at the atomic level.
Those wires are so tiny you
can't make them any smaller.
That is what's called
the end of Moore's Law.
So will the devices stop getting--
- And this is Gordon Moore?
- Gordon Moore, that's right, yeah.
- One of the founders of
Hewlett Packard I think,
is that right?
- Yeah, oh boy, you're
puttin' me on the spot here.
Either that or--
- Mr. Tech Journalist.
Or Fairchild Semiconductor,
I'm blacking out.
- But you know the issue.
When the wires are so small and
they reach atomic distances,
then quantum effects between
wires start taking over.
- Sweet.
- It is sweet.
That is awesome.
- So the wire, no longer
know that it's independent
of the wires sitting next to it.
- Absolutely.
- Because the wave function
talks to them both.
- Dude, that's amazing, I love it.
- So yeah, so they're
essentially having to figure out
how to make things faster
without making them smaller.
- Okay, so fine, so even if you
do level off at Moore's Law,
but presumably design can change.
Are there other limits?
Price, cultural, design?
- At the moment actually
weirdly one of the big limits
is how fast can you
get data to that device
from like a cell phone tower, you know?
That's almost a bigger limit now
than the speed of the phone.
- It's like cable TV,
you Know what I mean?
- They talk about how great your cable is,
we have this fiber optic and
whatever, that's like yeah,
I still got copper running into
my house, who gives a damn?
I actually fell for that
crap and I was just like
this is the exact same cable I had before.
- So can we think of these
smartphones as augmenting
our human physiology?
- Absolutely, sure, I mean
every technology we've had
has to a certain extent
as Marshall McLuhan put it
been an extension of man, right?
So TV extended our vision,
the phone extended our
ability to speak and talk.
These things are the strongest
extensions of humanity
that we've ever had.
And I would say that
you could think of them
as almost like a sense apparatus.
They're like a form of
ESP by which we tap into--
- Not ESPN.
- Not ESPN exactly.
(Chuck vocalizes)
- Okay, but a form of ESP.
- Yeah, you could of 'em as a sense of ESP
by which we sense what
other people are thinking
and talking about and
doing like all the time,
for good and for ill, right?
Because on the one hand, wow,
you learn a lot of great things.
On the other hand it's
almost like having telepathy
and being able to shut,
being unable to shut other
people's voices off in your head.
- In fact, when I tweet and I
look at the responses to that,
I usually tweet something
educational, it's my intent.
And I try to add a little
funny in it if I can,
do a little--
- You do a good job, I'm gonna say.
(Neil and Chuck talk over each other)
So I look at the response
to it and that informs,
I see that as a neurosynaptic snapshot
of the instantaneous
reaction to words I use,
to phrases I compose, to
ideas I put out there.
And then when I give a
public talk, I fold those in.
And I'm a way better
communicator because of it.
So that's my ESP in a sense,
getting inside the head
of a million people.
- I just figured out, I'm
doing Twitter all wrong.
(everyone laughs)
- Coming up more of my
interview with Marques
and it's an all, in
his capacity to tell us
what's going down in
the technology spectrum
when StarTalk returns.
We're back on StarTalk,
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson.
Co-host Chuck Nice, in studio
guest today, Clive Thompson,
a tech writer for the
New York Times and Wired
and other venues I presume--
- A few others.
- A few others, a few others.
We feature my interview
with Marques Brownlee.
He's a 20-something, early
20s reviewer of tech devices
that you might think of getting.
He does this on the internet,
has millions of followers.
And so I got here, sort of,
a interesting sort of perspective, okay?
On what role this portable
technologies might play today.
So I just had to ask him
what that relationship was
between these technologies and our lives,
let's check it out.
You've only really ever known the internet
as a thing in your life rather than having
to have transitioned from
walking to the library
to get information and data.
So to you, your life
is practically defined,
enabled by information
you get on the internet,
what those apps do for you
as you conduct your life.
So there's a certain amount of trust
that you place in this information,
in the integrity of this information.
- I have an app on my
phone called Google Now,
and if I go to class enough times
with my phone in my pocket,
it knows that I go there every day.
So it puts that down as where I work
but it knows I go there every day.
And if it's far enough away
that I drive there every day,
it'll start to show me
a card in the morning
of when I should leave based
on traffic to get there on time
because I go there the
same time every day.
So now it's helping me get there on time
because it knows where I go every day.
If there's an accident,
- So it's watching you.
it'll wake me up earlier to tell me
you should head out earlier.
- Because there's an
accident on the road there.
- There's an accident on the
road you're about to take
to get to the place you're about to go.
- And you're okay with all this?
- I'm okay with all of it
because it's helping me.
People don't like to think
that Google knows all this about us,
they're going to use this information
or even machines that are
collecting the information
can turn and use it.
I feel like if they're
giving back this information
to help me in this way,
that's actually really useful,
I'm okay with it.
- So I'm the senior citizen
among the three of us.
In my day, privacy was paramount.
- Absolutely.
- And I don't know that
this next generation
gives a rat's ass about privacy.
- Not at all.
- All their stuff is on the internet.
Their height, their weight,
their sexual preference,
their gender pronoun
and can you just offer
some reflections on the meaning of privacy
in the era of quote, helpful.
- It's definitely
changed a lot for exactly
the reasons we've been talking about.
It is sort of impossible
if you're young right now
to have a social life
without participating
in all these apps.
- [Neil] Social apps.
- Social apps, exactly.
Like whether that's Snapchat
or Facebook or whatever,
you're kind of off the grid.
And there are abstainers,
it's kind of funny.
You will find young people who are like,
I will have no truck with this.
But they're the ones who are
like kind of that iconic class
who don't really care about,
about having a big group of friends.
So I think one of the
problems young people have
is that they're,
it's not even necessarily that they have
a fundamentally different
attitude towards privacy
but they have no choice but
to do these types of things
in the same way that maybe
for us when we were younger,
not getting a driver's license
was sort of basically a vow
of I'm never going anywhere
that the cool kids are going, right?
You could have said--
- I grew up in New York City.
- Yeah, okay, I grew
up in Suburban Toronto
so you needed to drive.
So back then, if you opted
out from that technology,
you had a real social trouble, right?
- So these are cultural
social forces operating.
And if you're in the middle of it,
you don't even know that
there was another option.
- Yeah, but my problem is that there is,
you heard in his statement was resident
a certain amount of trust
in the responsibility
that Google has for--
- Yeah, yeah, he's
trusting these companies.
- [Chuck] He was very trusting.
- What's your trust level?
- Wow.
- I don't trust anybody.
Not in a conspiracy way,
it's just I don't want you
knowing this about me.
- Because it's power and
we all know power corrupts,
that's what I'm saying.
- Knowledge about you is power.
- Franklin Foer--
- We sound like old people
on the couch. (laughs)
- I was about to say,
lemme tell you something.
The only way this could have
got worse, here's Google,
okay, especially the black community,
here's Google if it had
been invented 25 years ago,
Google and the black community.
"Why don't you mind your damn business?"
(everyone laughs)
That's basically, that's
the response for, go ahead.
- Franklin Foer came up with a book,
he talks about big tech, right?
And he means the great big huge companies
that have massive amounts of power;
Facebook, Apple, Microsoft and Google.
And he makes a distinction between that
and like kind of smaller
tech which are companies
you might actually know and trust.
And I think that's a good distinction
because what you guys--
- No, but all those big
ones used to be little.
Don't tell me that.
They're just big now.
- I agree but like,
so the problem we have--
- [Neil] They weren't born big.
- But they're small tech,
you can completely trust,
like open source stuff like
the Tor Project, right?
So their whole point is
to try and make it easier
that you'd have privacy
online and it's open source
and it's like a run for
nonprofit, civic minded hackers.
There is technology out
there that you can trust,
it's not the stuff that is
big and is rewarded heavily
by the market.
(everyone talks over each other)
- It's all about the commercial entities.
- Is there anything out
there that you've said
yeah all right, that crosses the line?
- Oh yeah, sure.
I'll give you an example,
like so there was,
I came home from a summer vacation
and I opened up my Android
phone and Google said
hey we just put together a slideshow
of photos and like points on
a map of all that I'd done
the last two weeks just 'cause
we thought you might like it.
And it was so creepy, right?
It was super creepy.
- And I always turn my
locations off, okay?
But sometimes you forget
and I got that same doggone slide show
and it freaked me out.
- It doesn't matter, I'll tell you why.
- Why?
- I'll tell you why.
As I understand it, okay?
Can't Google now, if you put
your picture up in the cloud,
it can do an image recognition
of your surroundings,
compare it with all their satellite feeds
and say was this in the
Plaza de Piazza of the duh
and shall we ID it that way?
- Absolutely, in fact actually if you,
if you ask me for the technology right now
that most unsettles me,
it's the galloping roll out
of face recognition
technology into everything.
And so I'm like I don't want my microwave
recognizing my face.
I don't want omnipresence face recognition
all over the place, but
it's getting so easy to do.
I mean just the other
day Google helpfully said
hey guys, we just made TensorFlow,
our AI framework so it can run on
like basically a Raspberry Pi.
- Yeah, that's crazy,
that's insane by the way.
And let me tell you something else,
here's what really scares me
about the facial recognition.
aside from the fact that
I don't, like you said,
I don't want my microwave
recognizing my face
is the fact that once somebody
learns how to hack that
and make my face, like "Face Off" okay?
Now they could just walk around and be me.
- However, as I understand
it, it's not just,
it's better than what you would think,
it's better than how you would do
thinking that you're looking at yourself.
Because it's actually
measuring ratios of dimensions
of your face that are
extremely hard to duplicate.
- Oh no, I'm not talking about the,
I'm talking about going beyond
the actual facial recognition
where that I go in and
tell the software that,
so I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson.
- You hack it.
I hack and say, so now
everywhere Neil deGrasse,
everywhere I go,
- You're Neil deGrasse.
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson.
That's what scares me,
and it's going to happen.
- This brings us to, because
you can't outprogram it,
you can just hack it in the backend.
- [Chuck] Always go around.
- So this brings me to the concept
of internet identity, okay?
Who are you on the internet and how,
and privacy breaches, this sort of thing.
So I had to ask him,
Marques Brownlee just,
is the internet not only
helping us but now defining us?
Defining our identities
and what it kind of do,
let's check out the interview.
So is your life being defined
by all the ways the internet
inserts its way into your routine?
Because in my generation, it's still this,
it's a luxury, it's a
convenience, it's a tool.
It is not me.
- Right.
Has it become you?
- So I would say yes, the
internet is part of our life
and always has been in a way
that other generations exist
alongside the internet and may go over
and use it once in a while.
I feel like everything we do
now whether it's communication
or sharing anything with anyone,
whether it's someone I know
or just posting something
for the world, all of it
goes through the internet.
The convenience stuff like I said
where a normal going to work routine
would have no internet
involved in it in 1990,
today it's relying upon Google Maps
and my alarm clock on
my phone and everything
telling me when to wake
up and when to leave
and how to get there.
So in that way I do think
we are completely tuned
into the internet in a
way that's not the same
as any other generation, yeah.
- But can I say, it's not
that so much you are tuned
into the internet, the
internet's tuned into you.
- That also is true.
- Do you have an identity outside
of how you are represented
on the internet?
You've got a Facebook
page, this is what I am,
this is how I want the world to see.
- It's almost like a pair of identities
where you have your social life
but you have your social
media life as well.
And sometimes they're different.
You'd be surprised how different they are
with a single person having an online life
versus an offline life
which is kind of weird.
- Okay, how close are the two for you?
- For me I'm the same person.
- We'll be the judge of that. (laughs)
- You can look it up.
I'm out there, it's all the same.
- So I wonder, if and one
of my favorite comics from
was the 1990s New Yorker.
There's a dog at the computer.
You know the one I'm talking about.
And when he says to the dog next to him,
"Good thing about the internet,
"no one knows you're a dog." (laughs)
- That's pretty awesome, yeah.
- So what does it mean and how real is it
for people to just have a dual identity?
The internet identity and
then their actual selves.
- I'll bite that off first.
I mean we've always had
multiple identities.
In fact in the early 20th century,
and late 19th century, we
had a migration of people
from small towns to cities.
And one of the things I loved
about it was in the small town
everyone knew your business
and it was sort of impossible
to reinvent yourself or to
discover other sides of yourself
because everyone's like no,
that's not who you really are,
I know who you are Clive Thompson, right?
You go to the big city and
suddenly it's like lo and behold
wow, I could be someone different
or I could be a couple
of different people.
I'm one person at work and then I go off
and I do my thing with my crab.
- Just a quick thing,
there are people who say,
the city is so crowded,
I want to go out into
a rural suburban area
where no one will know me.
It's the opposite. (laughs)
- They will figure you out in 15 minutes.
- Yes, yes, whereas in the
city, no one gives, cares.
There's too many people to care.
- To know you.
- So I think having multiple
identities is actually healthy
and a good thing frankly.
- [Neil] You just said, repeat that.
- I think having multiple identities,
as long as they're not sociopathic
and you have like a different postal box
where you sort of order--
- Damn!
- (laughs) Chuck!
- For a moment I thought
I was getting approval.
- Anyway, that's healthy and
there's an extent to which
I think you see people
trying to do that online
and kind of failing
because large corporations
don't want you to have that.
They want to know everything about you,
they want to assemble it all in one place
so they can target ads at you.
This is Mark Zuckerberg's
original statement of Facebook,
having different selves is
a sign of inauthenticity.
And of course he's gonna say that
because he wants to have
everything about you
so he can target ads at you.
- And where he's, I was about
to say failing miserably
but then I thought this is who I am
and I'm saying that he's failing,
so that doesn't make sense.
But I think what he's not
taking into account is the fact
that when you do have
your different selves,
they can also be authentic.
- Sure, absolutely.
- You can have different selves
that are authentic selves.
- That's my point.
So I play in bands, I'm a journalist.
Often those two crowds have no idea
about the other part of me, right?
Like when I go and hang with musicians,
some of them don't read the stuff I do.
They're just that's Clive,
the guitar player, you know?
- [Chuck] Exactly.
- So ultimately are
there legal ramifications
to access to your private information?
- Well, I mean that's a good
question, I'm not a lawyer.
- And by the way who reads the...
- The disclaimer, the legal
disclaimer that when you
and I always thought that
when you click yes I agree,
that some type of really
weird things should happen.
Like you hear a knock on the door
and somebody's like yeah,
we're here for your wife, what?
Yeah man, when you click that agree...
- That's crazy stuff.
So I'm not a lawyer,
so I'm not gonna give
you a good legal answer
but it's definitely true that I think
one of the big issues right
now is like what protections,
legal protections do we have
for the way our data is used.
Now over in Europe,
they actually have a much different view.
Germany particularly 'cause
they have the Stasi, right?
So they have a lot of laws
and Google runs against these
and hates them and lobbies against them.
I think we probably need
much much better protections
in this country.
- Can and should an employer hold
your social media life against you?
- I don't think they should, no.
I really don't think they
should most of the time
particularly at the hiring level, right?
- [Neil] That's what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, at the level of hiring, okay.
- And then they say what have they posted
and what drunken pictures...
- I don't think that they
should be doing that stuff
because that's tantamount
to, in the pre-internet era
say hey can we come home and
just rummage around your house?
That was considered
unreasonable back then,
it should be similarly
considered unreasonable now.
- That's why I'm a comedian today.
All my stuff on social
media, I can't get a job.
- So you tell jokes about it.
- Sadly.
- We gotta take a break, but coming up,
more on the future of technology
when StarTalk returns.
We're back on StarTalk
and I've got my expert
guest, Wired magazine
and New York Times
columnist, Clive Thompson.
We're talking about the future
of technology, Chuck Nice.
So we're not experts at this
but we have strong opinions on it,
and he's got expertise so we're good.
And we're featuring my
interview with Marques Brownlee.
He's the 21, 22, 20 something year old
who's been reviewing technology
for everybody on the internet,
and YouTube in particular
with millions of clips.
So I had to ask him
where does he think technology is headed?
Let's check it out.
What are you gonna be telling your kids?
When you say, "Back in
my day when I was 22,
"look what we had to do, oh my gosh,
"can I have sympathy please?
- Honestly I'm thinking
cars, I'm hoping cars,
how we drive cars today and we--
- No, those will be really big gadget,
does that count as
something you would review?
- I count that, I'm in the car tech.
I've done a couple of videos
about cars and that's--
- So not just handheld,
anything electronic,
IT digital gadget.
- I say anything with
an on button is game.
Technically not every car has an on button
but if you look at some of
the more high-end cars today,
they've got electric systems
galore, plenty of high tech.
I feel like a lot of the stuff we have now
that's inside of a car
that you have to control,
like the steering wheel,
even if you're in a self-driving car
they still want you at the controls
in case something might go wrong
because it's a computer and it's a system.
- That's funny because the
fact that you say that implies
that something would go
wrong with the machine
that the human can correct,
rather than something
going wrong with a human
that the machine needs
to correct. (laughs)
Because last I checked,
all those accidents on the
street are humans messing up.
- For sure, but even the
systems getting to the point
where everyone has a car that
is capable of driving itself.
No one even needs that space
of a steering wheel in the car.
You just kind of sit down,
it's maybe a bench facing another bench
and you just kind of ride
along to your destination.
I feel like that's way down the road.
We're at the point where
a car is sort of fusing
into the next generation
of vehicle at this point.
- So if cars do all the
driving on the road,
then in principle you
can up the speed limit.
- Yeah.
(Neil laughs)
Absolutely.
- Right?
- 'Cause you're not at
risk of reaction time.
- Exactly.
- Because electrons react much
faster than the human brain,
even though there are
electrons in there somewhere
but wired for reacting
to traffic patterns,
a car can way outperform a human mind.
So I'm imagining you go
150, 200 miles an hour
driving down the road.
- No problem and they'll
just weave seamlessly
within each other in a
way that would be scary
if a human was trying to do it,
but it'll just be totally normal.
- That's right, because if
all the cars are going 200,
any high speed, then it's
a moving coordinate system
so that a car can move in and out of that.
- That's the other thing,
all the cars are sort
of talking to each other
as points in the matrix--
- I forgot about that.
- Sort of avoid each other
because they already know,
if car all the way on the right lane
with a bunch of stuff in between it
knows it wants to go to the left
and car all the way on the left
knows it wants to go to the right,
and they can tell the cars around it
I'm trying to go to the right,
I'm trying to go to the left,
human couldn't do that with another car
on the other side of the road.
- No, you can honk. (mimics honking)
"Let me in." (laughs)
- You can try but those machines
can work with each other
much more efficiently.
- I never considered that.
- Yeah.
So it's a ballet on the freeway.
- It's a symphony, it's beautiful.
- That's beautiful,
that's really beautiful.
Why do we get software updates?
Because they're bugs that
are found by the many users
that often the testing is
just let's put it out there
and see what comes back, right?
So self-driving cars
where lives are at risk,
what is the risk of there
being some kind of bug
where it kills people?
Or on top of that what's the
risk of hacking into a car
to create the accident in the first place?
- I think the hacking might be
a bigger risk than the bugs.
I mean regulatorily it's
gonna be tricky for them
to get those cars on the road.
'Cause cars are pretty tightly regulated
unless they can demonstrate
pretty persuasively
there isn't a lot of bugs.
Now hacking is a different thing,
because now you've got a human person
trying actively to break something, right?
And that's a much more volatile risk.
There's already been situations
where cars are out there
and Wired hired a couple of hackers
to literally take over a car
while it's going down the
highway and they did no problem.
So I think, I've driven
in self-driving cars--
- It's the diabolical division.
- Exactly, yeah.
I've ridden in Google's self-driving cars.
It felt pretty comfortable.
They're actually in a weird way,
they're almost sort of cautious drivers.
It's like being there with
your grandmother at the wheel.
Right now could get
faster as you point out
but overall if I were to
compare it to the dangers
of humans driving cars, I'm probably okay
with the self-driving cars
if it's well regulated,
that's the big if, right?
- So that's the future?
- I think so, yeah.
I mean I think it might
take longer than we think,
you're getting these rosy
predictions of five years.
- Yeah, I don't see five years.
But the fact is that they
are on the road right now,
they do work which I forget
that trucking company--
- Otto.
- Otto, so now Otto
has gone cross country,
traversed the country several
times with their semi.
And the only thing the human
being is doing is monitoring.
They have a guy that sits
there and monitors, that's it.
- And you could also, I mean frankly,
the other reason I'm
kind of in favor of it
is it has potentially great
environmental benefits, right?
Because you get way less idling,
you get way less jackrabbit starts.
These are things that burn huge amounts--
- What's a jackrabbit start?
- When you're at rest and
you suddenly burst off.
'Cause humans want accelerate fast
where my car's like I'm
just gonna east forward.
- Boy human testosterone.
Testosterone infused boy human.
- Exactly, yeah.
- (laughing) That's so true.
- I didn't learn how
to drive till I was 25
and that's after the
boy human testosterone
forces have dissipated.
- [Clive] Nicely done.
- Yeah, it was very, and you get lower--
- All boys should not
be able to do anything
until they're 25, let's be honest.
We're three men sitting
here, we know the deal.
If you're under 25 and you have a penis,
you're effing crazy, that's
all there is to it, okay?
There's something deeply
wrong with you, you need help.
You should talk to somebody.
(Neil laughs)
Okay, I'm sorry.
- Every single one.
- Every one of you, okay?
- So what intrigues me is when
you have a self-driving car
and it's talking to other
cars, there are signals,
there's, I just learned that Tesla is,
talks to other Teslas.
So if you come on to a bumpy road
and then you make the adjustment
to change your suspension
which of course you can do,
that information goes to the next Tesla,
any other Tesla that will be on that road
and it will preadjust the suspension
before it enters the
bumpy part of the road.
- See this is where the
stuff just gets creepy, man.
This is what I'm talking about, this is--
- Don't want your car to know?
- I don't want my car
talking to no other cars.
Do not talk to any other cars.
How many times do I have to tell you?
Don't talk to strangers, car.
Okay, stranger danger.
I don't want that Tesla just like--
- Don't you wanna know if
there's a hazard in the road?
- No, what I don't want is
that other Tesla saying,
"You know your owner doesn't love you."
- And the interesting point's gonna be,
will there come a point
when the government decides
that the self-driving
cars are so much safer
that it's illegal for
a human to drive a car?
- They could surely do that.
However, I've thought about this.
You cannot take a horse on the interstate
even though there's a day when horses
were the only things
that brought you around.
So now if you like horses
you go to a stables
where you can ride a--
- [Chuck] So we'll have race tracks.
- We'll have race tracks.
Then if you're still
a sports car collector
and you want to control your own car,
you take it to the sports,
that you have a berth
at the sports track, at the driving track
and that's where you drive
and you get your thrills,
just like the horseback riders do.
- So the Mustang will just
be, just like a real mustang.
You gotta go to the
ranch, go to the stables
and pull your Mustang out of the garage
to take it for a ride.
- Giddy up.
Oh man.
- I asked Marques, is there
any other future of technology
that he's excited about or
intrigued by, let's check it out.
When you're the ripe old age of 32,
how do you want to be living life?
What technology do you
want to be surrounding you?
- Wow, 10 years from now, let's see.
I hope car tech is on another level,
I hope that's the most exciting part.
- And that's the right
horizon for this to kick in
if it's gonna do it, all right.
- I hope the handheld devices we have
are no longer handheld,
and that's pretty ambitious
for 10 years I think.
But communication--
- Where are they?
Well someone would argue
they're like in your arm
or attached, you've seen
wearable tech smartwatches
that kind of shrink down
and end up on your wrist
or on your ear and around on your neck
or something like that.
- But how about the biology
technology interface?
- [Marques] Interfusion?
- Yeah, put a little USB thing right here.
- Yeah, right in your neck--
- They kind of did that
in, no one called it that
but there were USB ponytails in "Avatar".
Remember that?
Where they'd take their hair
and they'd plug into the plant
and they would communicate
with one another.
- That's weird.
- [Neil] USB ponytail,
that's what that was.
- Yeah, that's the kind
of thing I see though
is like a much more portable
but complete version
of your digital self to just exist
and be able to move around.
- So Clive, how real is this interface
of biology and technology?
And I ask because do I need my iPhone
neurologically attached to me
when it's sitting at my
fingertips to begin with.
Is that the same thing?
- It's awfully intimate right now, right?
It's right there.
- [Neil] Completely.
- Yeah, they talk about
wearable technology.
We already have wearable technology.
We're all carrying phones with us, right?
- [Neil] It's in my pocket.
- But there's people working,
Google's working on these contact lenses
that display technology on them.
They're working on that quite seriously.
- So any ethical frontiers here
that we don't know about yet?
Bioethical.
- I mean the bioethical
frontiers concerns are always,
do you produce something that's great
for intelligence, performance and ability
but is it so expensive that
only rich people get it?
- I heard a rebuttal to
that from Ray Kurzweil
'cause we had him on StarTalk, all right?
He said no that's not a problem,
the haves and the have-nots
and I said why?
He said because when it first comes out,
it never works well anyway and
it's stupendously expensive
and it's not, and so yes,
only a few people have it
but only when it becomes mass-market
does it become truly functional.
- That's true.
- He's right, when phones first came out,
you had to be pretty rich to get a phone.
- First computers were pretty useless.
- They're useless and the first phones
are completely useless and
the ones that are mass-market
are the ones that are most,
so that's why I don't
see that as a problem.
- I mean I hope he's right shall we say.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Clive, it's been great having you.
- It's been great being on,
great conversation guys.
- We gotta bring you back.
We'll surely find some other excuse.
- Yeah, you're much
better than the other--
(Neil and Chuck laugh)
- I appreciate it.
- Well cool, Chuck, any
final thoughts here?
- No, I just think that
this is a very scary time
if you're--
- A happy thought, Chuck.
Oh, I'm sorry, technology is wonderful.
I'm so happy that we have it, yes
and I think the human race
is so much better off now
though we all have our faces
stuck in some stupid phone
instead of talking to one another.
- I think we are still in our infancy.
Do you know it took multiple centuries
after the printing press
before anyone figured out
that you could make
something called a newspaper?
- [Chuck] True.
- So it was you had broadsheets and things
but a routinely produced newspaper,
that took like 400 years,
300 something years.
So here we are at the
dawn of the internet,
even though it's 10, 15, 20 years old,
I think we don't yet know,
we're still playing with ourselves, right?
And I don't think we have,
I think there's a level of maturity
of how to use the power of this technology
that we have yet to attain.
- I just love that you
said level of maturity
after you said playing with yourself
and I'm sitting here like I can't help it.
By the way the number one
thing that the internet causes,
people playing with themselves.
- So I just think there's a
level of technological maturity
that we have yet to achieve.
And I don't know when, is it
50 years, is it 100 years,
150 years, I don't know.
But only then can we really
say that it doesn't own us,
we own it.
You've been watching and
probably more likely listening
to StarTalk, and I've been
your host, Neil deGrasse Tyson,
your personal astrophysicist.
Chuck, thanks for being here.
Clive, good to have you.
And I publicly thank Marques Brownlee
for agreeing to that interview.
And until next time as always
I bid you to keep looking up.
(funky music)